everybody's process is different and I
know when I learned a lot of that
process and would listen to other people
you know you take it really seriously
what people who have succeeded you know
do have done it's like all I've got to
do it that way and I do my stuff very
specific to me you know and and it and
it'll work for anybody if you just do it
but at the same time you know it's like
I just I hope it's like it feels like
it's opening up like this is just what I
do but don't you know don't you don't
have to do this you know this is just
yeah yeah oh no it's not coming across
as like you know no no not not at all
okay no you're not stopping people do
yeah they'll be but I think it's good
too because you know people could dig a
little bit from here and a little bit
from there but ya know it's not coming
off as this is the ultimate way they're
very different it's one of the few
mediums that you actually get a
possessory credit you know you've seen
you know Neil Simon's Plaza sweet I mean
occasionally you see Lee Daniels movie
and so forth but by and large the writer
is really the words are really so much
more of the focus and the writer is
really respected you know so much more
in theatre but it's a different kind of
medium altogether you get to write in
theatre you get to write stories that
are you know can be very personal and
it's very intimate and very small and
really character driven and really you
know where the where the words are just
important and it's all that dialogue and
and all of that I had a funny experience
when I when I thought screenwriting firm
it for many years with it for a group
called writers boot camp and and I had a
student who was a great great woman
she's an actress and she was always kind
of bucking me about you know structure
and like why do I have to structure
things this way and don't you why do you
know can't you loosen up in terms of
this and that and I would just try to
explain to her how structure and
storytelling you know worked a certain
way so she came to see the plight was my
very first play was a long time ago and
she walked out and she said to me she
hugged me and she says I I love the play
but I love the words she's I love that
you who's you know who's teaching me
structure that you wrote these amazing
words that were just words it was all
words and character and as an actress
that's you know that was her priority
you know great words and great character
and it was really like very eye-opening
to me that
you know how how really how different
words are when it comes to to theater
because you know it movies are about
showing not telling very very often
because you have the ability to show a
lot of things without having to explain
a lot of things whereas in theater you
have it's just much much more limited in
terms of what you can show so you end up
telling more and that can be very
interesting you know and writers enjoy
telling stories which you can do on
stage so I like that the live the live
part of it I write a lot of comedies and
and to to be with an audience and and to
to be in an audience a live audience to
where they're laughing and really
responding and crying or whatever and to
be around them live even different than
being in the theater watching you know
watching people watch your movie it's
it's different there's something about
the live experience that's really you
know very it's just very moving and you
know very compelling so you know that
part is great and I don't know I think
as a writer you know I always encourage
people write screenwriters to write
plays as well I did it as a kind of way
to I wrote my first play at a time where
I just had a little time and I needed to
get something done that was mine you
know that like I didn't have to worry
about selling I didn't have to worry
about it you know fitting any particular
paradigms I could tell the story that I
wanted to tell and and it just happened
to have worked out play play was I was
very proud of the play we actually did a
staged reading of it and I was just
surprised that the response to it and
then you know I was just encouraged to
you know get the play produced and we
did and it was a really fantastic
experience you also as the writer get to
deal very directly with the actors and
the director in it in a very different
way than you do in TV and film and
because because it's really more that
team effort at that particular moment
particularly if it's a new play that
you're kind of still discovering the
words and working on the words as you're
in rehearsals and I'm also very I've
always been whether it's you know in the
film I've written or or a play I'm very
interested in hearing what the actors
have to say because just because you
write a piece of dialogue a certain way
doesn't mean that that somebody who's
has to say it can say it that way or can
say it can say it in a comfortable way
and how in my in my head I hear it a
certain way and when it comes out of
somebody's mouth it may be different
it's always fascinating to see which
lines really don't play and really are
too tongue twister Eeyore really really
don't make as much sense as they do and
you have that option when you're in
rehearsal live at that moment and it's
an evolutionary process we have a stage
play that you're producing coming up
yeah that that I'm not producing it's a
theater called Theatre 40 in Beverly
Hills it's produce they're producing it
they have a they've been there a long
time it's a really really good 99-seat
theater and they have a subscription and
they do a season and this is the fifth
that at the sixth six plays of their
2016-17 season
it's called April May and June and it's
going on that it's gonna run from March
16th through the middle of April April
16 okay and and it's a story of three
adults sisters who named April May and
June they're in their 40s they're a year
apart and they convened at their late
mother's house which is the house they
grew up in to go through the very end
the very last of her things and in doing
so they discover something about the
mother that they just blows their mind
and it's in a small way it's a surprise
but in a small way connected to them and
their own past and and it's kind of how
they end up coming to terms with their
image of the mother and the whole idea
we never quite know people as much as we
think particularly parents and the
sisters were three very different but
very connected clothes women are they
they're their relationship is really
improved by this afternoon they spend in
their childhood house and it's just how
they come to terms with each other and
and the image of the mother and they can
finally you know close up the house and
move on so when you sat down to write
that were you in the same mindset of I
just want to do something that's my own
or was there some other well what
happened was I in this particular case I
and this happens every so often with a
film script particularly I'll come up
with a title and I just happened to the
the title April May and June just came
into my head for some reason I go that's
a good
idle I should do something with that and
I don't know it's just I just started
writing it it ended up becoming a you
know a play a stage play I wasn't
exactly sure where it was going when I
started at a certain point I realized
that was going to be this revelation
about the mother I realized what the
revelation I wanted it to be and it kind
of evolved them from there you know and
and so it was kind of it was kind of a
unique process that way as opposed to
like having it completely structured and
having a full outline and really knowing
where I was going and then you know I
wrote it and then edited it and
ultimately got it to the place where I
felt comfortable sending it out of
showing it but it was it was a very
different process than then this is the
screenwriting that I do so it's that
common that you will just come up with a
title and then work back once in a while
I do that once in a while you know what
happens you know especially if I were
this this this play is a comedy drama
this and you know I hope good laughs in
it but there's also you know a lot of
tears in it as well so but on a lot of
just straight comedies that I do you
know just higher concept comedies I've
come up with titles and and then figured
out the story to go with it now if this
if there was no story attached I
wouldn't continue writing it and then
there are movies that I've written that
I've ended up changing the title many
times over things so it just you know it
depends but once in a while it's a you
know you think about how do you people
say how do you get the idea to write
this so weird we're to come up with whoa
thought of something like that well you
know we're writers and we write and
we're storytellers and we're creators
but sometimes they come from strange
places it can be from something that
you've observed it can be from people
that you know it can be from just coming
up with a phrase or or or or in this
case a title so it's just one of those
weird you know weird things we referring
back to the stage play that you've just
written and are now showing and coming
up in March April May and June
she had the title how long did it take
you to finish well that that particular
play took took a while because I was on
a bunch of assignments of a bunch of TV
movie assignments during the course of
well two actually during that period but
I wrote it over the course of about six
months so every time I had a little
downtime from the films I was writing I
I went back to the play which is kind of
a harder way to do it I mean usually I
try to write work on one thing and just
start go start to finish and then
move on to the next thing second focus a
little bit more but in this particular
case I again I started and not quite
knowing where it was going so every time
I came back to it even if a few weeks
had passed or whatever it was like it
was like starting over again but it
actually worked in the plays favorite
because it became this very interesting
kind of the way the way the story kind
of spins out and the way that the
characters stories and the dialogue
spins out it's just it's it's slightly
less linear then then other things that
I've written which I kind of like you
know it's in the tie it's all one
timeline but but the convert there's a
lot of conversation and it doesn't it
doesn't all necessarily just follow you
know clink into place which which which
I think will be really interesting to
hear so that was a little bit different
but generally I like writing things you
know pretty much we start to finish
however long it would take but if I had
to compress all the time yeah I would
say over the course of about a month to
write it three weeks maybe you know and
then there's all the rewriting and and
now we're in rehearsals and you know
we're working on the words and tinkering
and you know seeing what things sound
right and what don't and what words we
need a better word for something that
explains things better you know it's
it's the process yeah so someone who's
used to writing in the the typical
screenwriting structured format you know
how would they switch gears a little bit
and maybe there's books you can
recommend on how to do stage plays well
I I basically think you can write a
stage play pretty much you can structure
pretty much the way you structure a film
film is most films are have a classic
structure classic storytelling structure
to them by and large they do and and a
play plays the nice thing about plays is
that they can be this big sort of jumble
of ideas and and time frames and things
that you know don't have to always be
all that linear and all that structure
however ultimately if you even break
down those there is a structure to it so
I think if you go by the classic
storytelling structure you know where
the mid let's say the mid point of the
movie is that point of acceleration with
is that new piece of information or that
surprise or something that sends the
story in a whole new direction by the
end of your first act of a two-act play
basically that midpoint is like that oh
my god moment and
yeah the stage goes black and everybody
walks out in the lobby like oh what's
gonna happen that's kind of what you're
what you're looking for you have a low
point
you know it's probably the 3/4 point the
kind of all is lost moment you have a
1/4 point let's say where it where might
be what what's normally called in a
script page 30 or the end of for act 1
but in a play you have that kind of
quarter point where where the the the
action kind of shifts and they're kind
of off on the journey
you know plays tend to have a lot of
preamble to them a lot of just
conversation and getting to know
characters and and until you sort of get
into the meat of it's you're setting up
the world in a little different way that
then you then you can in in a film so it
can take a little while to get into the
real meat of the story but even then I
think in this play at that quarter point
what would be the middle of the first
act of the play you end up with that
kind of incident that kind of moves
twisted it moves it in that in that
slightly new direction that leads to the
end of the first act with the moment of
acceleration so I think then it's not a
dissimilar structure and I'm so you
frankly I'm so used to writing things in
so many films in basically classic
structure that it's sort of second
nature in terms of how I'm gonna write a
play but plays do have more freedom you
know generally just like with the
actress that kind of gave you a hug at
the end and and was interested in the
way you approached it and and structure
versus you know what she'd been used to
sort of working with what do you want an
audience member to get from one of your
plays aside from showing up that's a
great thing yeah good people in the
seeds no but aside from that when the
curtain goes down and they don't come
out and bow what do you want them to
experience I I'd like them to feel that
they were that they spent an hour and a
half or two hours with people that they
knew with people that they could relate
to you know I've written a lot of plays
that are very character oriented very
people-oriented very fan a lot of family
family and relationship comedies and
things and you just want people to to
feel like they've experienced something
that they can really relate to and in
this particular case in April May in
June so many people have gone through
that experience of you know everybody's
either a child or a pet has been
and or apparent and often you've lost
the parent by the time you get to the
theater you probably of an age where
maybe you've lost the parent or you've
lost the grandparent or you know
somebody who has so I think there's a
lot of relatable things and then the the
sibling part of it you know I want
people to say that reminds me of my my
sisters and my brothers and my cousins
or that's just like cousin so-and-so or
whatever whatever I think there'll be a
lot of that kind of recognition so I
want people to be moved you know by move
by the characters that are created and
the kind of relating to the whole idea
of that yes we don't always know our
parents and our parents don't always
know us and maybe they'll go home and
spend a little time talking to their
parents before it's too late
ask that question tell me about that
thing that I know don't know you know
say to you pet you say to your mother
say to your father if you were to die
tomorrow what would I discover going
through your things that you'd rather
tell me about now so I won't have a lot
of questions you know so I think there's
a lot of food for thought you know that
hopefully out of this play will come and
and generally with plays they just want
people to feel not just that they had a
good time and whatever but they really
got something out of there was an
emotional connection that they got out
of it you know that they can then take
with them and it can resonate
how often do you write Oh that's a good
question people always say like how can
you be so disciplined to just sit in
your office and write all the time well
I don't write all the time if it was
Tardos and and but but I would say if I
don't write it doesn't happen not like
going into an office and having a job
and and having specific tasks and things
like that and having meetings set up for
you I mean you know if you're if you
write writing on TV staff is a little
different but if you basically writing
whether it's on spec or writing on
assignment and you're in your own space
you have to you have to get the work
done you have to create you know your
schedule so I find that when I'm on a
tighter deadlines I write much more I
write much faster I'm up earlier I up
later I a certain amount of adrenaline
takes over where you just get it done
if I'm not in an assignment I'm writing
something for myself or I've got a
little time for something or I'm
preparing for a meeting that's a week
ago a way instead of tomorrow
I'll take a little bit more time but
basically every day you know I'm always
in work mode and I'm always working on
something writing something putting
pitches together working on rewriting I
always go and back and rewrite old
scripts that I think still have life in
them that we can maybe try to try to
sell as the scripts have strange lives
that they have nine lives in some
respects because you can write something
and I have scripts I've written ten and
even fifteen years ago that didn't sell
then but suddenly there's a reason that
something's out in the zeitgeist now
that if I just make some tweaks and sort
of you know modernize it a little bit or
updated then it may have a life to it
and I do that a lot so when I have a
little downtime I always go back to the
old scripts but I've I've had a long I
had a had a long stretch of a pretty
regular assignment work so that has kind
of kept me in a pretty you know pretty
dedicated and consistent work mode but
you know I I'm I let's put this way I'm
much happier and much saner when I'm
writing a lot you know and free time
free time is fine but I I do I just
enjoy you know having having that
project that I'm working on so so I try
to write as much as I can
were you always that dedicated and
structure to me
was that something overtime that
developed I've been I've always been
pretty like whatever jobs I've had I've
been organized and even in school I was
organized you know not like you know
fanatically but you know I'm pretty good
it's sort of knowing how to get things
done in a quick way and and not lose too
much time
you know prioritizing is very important
and and because when you have a limited
amount of time to get something done you
really have to you have to kind of vote
be careful that you're not getting lost
in the minutiae of things and really
stay focused on the bigger picture and
the overarching story and the bigger
structure of something then then playing
with every little word you can get soul
as a writer you can get so lost in the
in in what somebody I know wants very
accurately called swirling the words you
know where you just you know you get the
script written and then you spending all
this time making every word perfect and
you know rearranging things and you know
we all want things to be as greater than
as what we consider perfect as possible
but then the movie gets made and there
are millions of changes along the way
and tons of things are cut and sometimes
you know what's being done sometimes you
don't know what's being done so you have
to really not over the course of time
I've learned to to really manage the
time I spend on things and not get too
caught up in the minutia of things which
is kind of easy to do so but I yeah I
mean I've been pretty good at
organization and get any things done and
I'm fairly quick and then I can write
fairly quick I can rewrite fairly
quickly over the course of time I press
ever ate a lot less on honest on a
script or a story or a pitch I want it
like I said I want it to be great but I
kind of I'm sort of good at letting
things breathe and evolve a little bit
more to get to the point that they need
to be how do you know if you're getting
caught up in the minutia because I think
as creative people we think it's
something huge but really it's not I
mean I was very easy to get lost I mean
you know especially again if you're not
on a schedule you're not on a timetable
or you're not watching the clock it's
very easy to get lost now by the same
token I'm I'm a big believer and like
sometimes you just have to just write
stuff out and just just you know have it
in your head and just get it down on the
page and not edit yourself to sort of
you know like like blow it out and I
think sometimes that's very helpful to
get to the to the s and to find the
essence of what you're really trying to
do but I
think you know I I think I think it
comes just an experiment with experience
frankly I think it's really just the
more things you've written and the more
ways you understand how to how to best
tell and structure a story so that it'll
be the most effective that it'll hit the
marks that somebody you're somebody's
hiring you is looking for you know if
you're working for a film company or a
network or producer who has certain
paradigms mandates things that work best
for them
you know you focus on those things
because there's just some when you're
writing for other people sometimes
there's so much you can of yourself that
can be in that script you know you have
you know you're trying to try to fill a
number of boxes and and it's a little
different than just writing something on
spec or like writing a stage play which
is which is for you so you learn how to
adjust the amount of time you spend on
things what you focus on what is
important what's probably less important
what's gonna change was probably not
gonna change because we have a finite
amount of time to do things Gary if
writing was not your career would you
still write and what would you write
that's an interesting question you know
people look people often say like you
people are always asked if you weren't
an actor what would you do if you
weren't a chef what would you do it's
hard to say because I I always I was
always a writer as always I was loved
words my mother was somebody who was
like very word oriented and if you'd use
a word wrong she'd correct you and she
was a big crossword puzzle person and
Scrabble and she and I and I so learned
a lot of my love of words from her my
grandfather in an era where where men
didn't necessarily take a great interest
in you know all things intellectual he
was a he was a crossword puzzle fanatic
and he actually created his own
crossword puzzle encyclopedic
dictionaries basically that he hand
wrote in the most beautiful handwriting
and I still have him to this day and he
he was I was really young when he went
he was alive but but he really taught me
a lot about words and I learned a lot
about words from from his love of words
so that was something that came to me
from it from an early age when I was in
high school I was a film reviewer for
the high school paper I wrote different
articles the high school paper I wrote
for the the literary magazine I was a
staff writer on the my college paper I
was always were
I worked a lot in the journalism world
which I still do and I and I so I've
always loved that kind of writing so I
guess I was it's kind of where it was
meant to be I had a first career out of
college as a publicist movie publicist
and I did that for a while and I enjoyed
it and it actually it actually was
interestingly and actually combined my
love of movies and writing but because
because I was promoting movies and I you
know the word was so important in terms
of getting things out to people whether
it was a pitch whether it's a
conversation whether as a press release
whatever but at a certain point I
realized I I had to I had to get back to
my first love which was writing and so I
left that world and I started writing TV
scripts and started getting work in
television and episodic television which
then sort of moved me into movies and
then stage plays and then TV movies and
all of that so it's kind of it's evolved
a lot over time looking back to those
years as a publicist and I don't know
what those years were what do you see as
a different landscape and maybe a
tougher landscape or easier for people
trying to promote their films today oh
well you know you've got social media
you know I mean I I when I started you
know social media was kind of you know I
mean it was sort of in the nascent
stages and you know but really wasn't
part of things you know people were
still you know faxing things I mean you
know I mean it was it was kind of a
different period now I think and even
like with this play or anything else
that on that I'm doing between Facebook
and Twitter and any kind of social media
or the Internet itself you can just do
so much more promotion so much more
stuff a homegrown promotion that cost
them very little if anything so that's a
big deal you know so you don't have to
depend upon running newspaper ads to
promote something or or radio ads or
whatever I still think all that's really
important you know but if you have the
budget but when you're doing a smaller
project is not always the place for that
so you've got you've got social media in
the internet which is a huge thing what
you didn't have back then I think it
makes a big difference but on the flip
side would you say in some sense that
could also be a detriment because now
there's so many things competing for
people's attentions that stuff is so
short-lived yeah it is well I mean if
you look at television they're about 500
TV series altogether on every platform
you know with the idea
also you know diffused ratings of so
much less you know individual ratings
are so much less there's just so much
more to take people's attention so yes
that the lancing the entertainment
landscape is more difficult than it used
to be because of of all the different
opportunities that people have but
things find their place you know when it
comes to theater people still go to the
theater when it comes to movies in a
movie theater people still go to the
movies in a movie theater well all of
that people still watch network
television so it's just about keeping
people focused on it and it's and it's
who's making the most noise you know
it's really what it is
so because we have all this this new
media and because we have so many
opportunities to promote things and get
the word out and you know word-of-mouth
the concept of word-of-mouth has always
been around I mean you know people
forever people have said oh what makes a
successful movie oh it's just really
word of mouth it's not necessarily
reviews or this or that is word-of-mouth
you know somebody saying I saw this I
loved it you've got to go see it so you
still have that and there are new ways
of getting that word about that now so
it's it's probably a trade off in a way
you know but ultimately I think we're
probably it's probably easier to promote
things now I know we wanted to speak to
you primarily about writing but just a
couple quick questions regarding from
the eyes of the publicist I know you
don't do that anymore but what did you
see with a lot of filmmakers and I
realize a lot has changed in whatever 10
years or how it's been but um what do
you see from a lot of filmmakers that
were some mistakes and then some things
that were very positive of they did to
promote their film oh well a lot of
filmmakers when I was doing publicity
and it may be the same now I don't know
but a lot of filmmakers were kind of
against the concept of publicity or
promotion or anything that seemed too
cheap in the movie you know we want the
movie to stand on its own or speak for
itself
nowaday you know and sometimes you could
do things to promote the movie and other
times you were more limited depending
upon the kind of movie it was now I
would suspect that people are much more
interested in promotion because it is so
much harder to get people in to see
things and there is so much more you
know visual traffic out there so
probably hopefully they're more open to
it and also because there's so much more
media now
available to promote something I think
and also you know a lot of interviews
sometimes they're done Q&A is there done
by emailing in you know your answers and
things like that so it's a little bit
easier and it for a lot of people who
aren't that comfortable doing interviews
or actors who are uncomfortable do it or
in a different location and can't do it
so hopefully they're just more open to
what's out there and the fact that you
have to promote things to get people in
there you know people just don't find
things they don't just discover things
anymore and you know and you don't have
the time to have things sit there to be
discovered if a movie doesn't nobody
sees it that first weekend it's gone you
know in a play is there is not the
similar and the only books seem to have
a little bit more time to kind of grow
and and get the word of mouth that they
don't have to take it out of a theater
or something they just have to keep it
on the shelf and you know hopefully
there's room on the show on the
bookstore shelf or certainly on the
amazons or the websites you know it's
this it's infinite amounts of room so I
think you know in that world you know
it's still pretty safe but yeah I think
promotion is very important and I and I
always encourage people to you know to
promote their work because you want
people to see it you know you you know
right unless you're writing for yourself
or writing in a vacuum you know you it's
a lot of work you want people to just
see it and enjoy it well do you notice
that it seems like maybe more the actors
or the producers are fine with doing
promotion and interviews but the writer
director wants to say removed well I
can't speak for directors but writers
you know the writer nature the kind of
basic writer nature is generally at
least looked at or thought of as being
you know more more low-key more reserved
quieter more Bellone er you're in your
office or your room writing all the time
by yourself you know there's a little
different mindset a little different hat
that that you're wearing and so a lot of
writers are just not as comfortable
doing that but these are the same
writers that have to go into meetings
and pitch an idea and put on a show
basically for an executive or producer
to try to sell something and are good at
that so it's really not that much
different you know you're still putting
yourself out there having to speak I
mean some people are just more
comfortable in front of you know in
front of an audience you know that other
people are but but yeah I think writer
is it's probably not quite
certainly not as as kind of inherent and
you know who they are versus like an
actor to go out and promote something
and what about the filmmakers who feel
that it in some sense cheapens their
work yeah by promoting and I get how
someone could feel that huh but also
people want to see who is I mean I think
if it's some movie that there's some
cheap promotional stunt is being done
that's sort of crass or something yeah I
mean there's no reason for that but that
probably not going to do that for you
for the movie unless it happens to be a
movie with that we're you know that's
the tone of the movie and that would
work by and large you know the concept
of promoting movies or TV shows or books
or plays or anything it's usually high
quality high quality interviews and high
quality things that that people will
that will get people to go see something
so you know I just I think sometimes you
can't look too deeply into all that you
just do it and hope that people respond
and then lastly when someone is
interviewed and they're about to you
know meet the press or go to a junket
whatever how much should they know their
own backstory and and really have
something interesting to give people
about who they are personally not just
the film and want to thank the actors
and all that but people really want to
know stuff about the filmmaker well I
think as a gal I can speak for
screenwriters I think as a writer
it's really important to kind of just
kind of remember how you why you wrote
something how you got to write it what
it means to you you know sometimes we
especially if we read a lot of things we
can forget what each individual project
why it's important to us so what
motivated us to do it or what our
intention was it's very important to
kind of reconnect with that I think
before you you know do an interview I
think I think the writer brings a very
very unique perspective to a - talking
about a film because you know the film
exists because something was written you
know so it's kind of the foundation so
you've created this that you you
basically unless you're adapting
something you've pretty much created the
world that this film was then you know
created from so I think you have to be
aware of that foundation be able to talk
about you know again how it where it
came from it asked me about where the
play came from and you know the title
and all of that I mean it just
everybody's got their story so I think
you have to
you know be aware of your backstory and
then what your intentions are what you
hope people will will get from what what
they see of your work and what you know
again what your what your real intention
is in putting together a story do you
remember the first time someone paid you
to write oh god yeah my very first paid
assignment was an episode of Saved by
the Bell that the Saturday morning TV
show and it's a funny story because the
show had I think it was like its second
season there's a long time right when I
first started writing and I remember I
write my agent said well there's this
show
it's a Saturday morning kids show it's a
live-action show that you know they need
writers they like to writing writing
samples you want to go in and pitch and
I go well why you sending me there I
want to write you know whatever it was
back there cheers or Murphy Brown or
what I want to write one of those
because just go you know just go it'll
be fun and and they'll probably hire you
whatever so I go in I pitched a ton of
stories they picked one they liked it
and they shot and they shot it and it
was a nice experience well on the aside
from just first getting getting my first
credit and all of that that episode has
rerun 50,000 times on one platform or
another the show became very successful
it became like this iconic show of its
period it went onto DVD and you know so
the episode is on all the DVDs and to
this day I can I can write something
that was really successful and though
and the one thing somebody will say to
me when I tell them I wrote Saved by the
Bell
I love that show I remember your episode
oh my god wait till I tell so-and-so
that you wrote that episode of Saved by
the Bell you know it's just it's really
funny so it turned out to be a great
first assignment you know that little
did I know but that was the first time I
was actually paid as a screenwriter and
which episode was I wrote an episode
called save the max
which was about the kids unearthed the
old high school radio station that they
find in a basement or something and they
use it to create a telethon kind of
Radiothon to save their their diner the
max which is going to close because
they're going out of business of
something and yeah and that was it and
and it's just funny because people just
they know it and they remember it it's
like culty almost you know so so I you
so I just say if it makes sense take the
job because you never know what's going
to come up
right it's so going back to that first
time you know knowing that you did get
the job what was going through your head
like the night of the night yeah when
you found me I found when I found out
that I got the job
oh it was it was huge because you know I
had just started writing and and I had
been working a lot writing spec scripts
and going on meetings and things like
that and and I had the job I had had I
was doing pretty well in it and and and
I just kind of figured when I left that
job well well you know I've gotten jobs
I you know it hasn't been that hard to
find jobs I'll I'll do this and I'll get
a job you know it just I wasn't prepared
for how difficult it was and maybe if I
was I wouldn't have done it so I just
went in like you know optimistic and and
you know full steam ahead
so to get my first writing job
relatively soon after I after I started
you know well left that other job and
started writing it felt like this is
huge accomplishment and and it was fun
and I I didn't write a second opus or
any other episodes for them but I did go
up back in there and pitch a few times
and and yeah it was it was very exciting
but you know what to this day when
somebody says yes to something it's the
greatest feeling you know it's just it's
so it's a validation and you know you're
just so proud of the fact that you know
you really you came up with an idea
somebody liked it somebody's gonna you
know you can't get it get to write it
you know you can't get to tell your
story you know it's always exciting when
you left that other job did you have a
specific plan in place like okay I'm
gonna give myself this much time if it
doesn't work out then here's Plan B I
never had a plan B the funny stuff my
family started my sister after I left
the job and yeah after doing this for a
few years and you know it definitely had
its ups and downs she said to me well do
you have a plan B and I said no this is
my plan B I my plan a was that other job
then that didn't work out for me so this
my plan B actually became my plan a so
that's it and I always I just always
stuck it out I mean you know I I always
you know I love writing I was I never
got the don't quit your day job I got
enough work along the way to to know I
should keep doing it until things
ultimately became more consistent and I
always did other writing work to fill in
in between you know whether it's
journalism work or press kit writing or
publicity writing or whatever I was
eating something so it in between all
the scriptwriting just to sort of keep
going and to make money but you know I
just never gave up and and I just always
believed in in the the possibility of
success whatever level of was you know I
mean I think you have to manage your
expectation in terms of where what your
place may be in the food chain but you
know I love writing there's really not
much else I'd I'd want to do I'd love to
you know be a chef I'd love to be a
psychiatrist I'm you know a psychologist
I mean I there are lots of things I'm
interested in but you know when it comes
to you know to my passion you know it's
really writing we talked about how you
sold your first screenplay what was it
oh okay
I had been writing television I had been
writing episodic television and getting
assignments and things but I wasn't I
didn't get on staff on a show I it was
hard to do it was at the time where they
gave out more freelance assignments on
TV shows than they do now but still the
whole point was to get on staff on a
show and I was just finding that that
that wasn't the so the direction
everything was moving in so I decided to
start writing screenplays because I
always loved movies and that's kind of
what I started off wanting to do but I
felt TV would be kind of a good way to
enter the business and-and-and something
a little more accessible which I think
it was but I started just writing a
screenplay so I took a couple of courses
about writing a screenplay I took a
great class called writers boot camp
which I ended up teaching for a long
time a few years after I took it and I
never wrote a few scripts and sort of
got on the I think they I got they got
attention if you've got option things
happen and then ultimately I just kept
writing spec screenplays you know I mean
they you have to keep writing if you
know if you if you're not getting
assignment work and you have the time to
write you know to write on spec you have
to keep cranking things out so at that
particular point in in in the movie
business a lot of this was a little bit
after the big million dollar spec sales
and all of that where you know like
everything was selling but I sort of
missed that way but but but high concept
comedies were kind of
they were you could sell them you know
they had to be good that'd be a good
idea but they were saleable now it's
different I mean now it's the studios
and making fewer of them it's harder to
sell those now unless it's like a big
star attached to it but back then there
was it was just that was just kind of
like the bread and butter I mean
everybody wanted those scripts so I
wrote a script called Manhattan Transfer
which was about a New York radio shrink
sort of a shock jock of a radio shrink
who on one day starts starts taking on
the neuroses of all of his callers at
the time that he's making the very week
he's making the leap from local radio to
national television as a shrink as a you
know as a in it as TV shrink and and
it's just the story of how he gets
through this period of time and he hooks
up with his old old graduate school
girlfriend who turns out to be his young
son school psychologist and she can help
some as a psychologist on his journey of
getting through this crazy week when
he's taken on the transference of all of
the all of his clients neuroses in his
whole his whole thing as the shock jock
is neuroses are all in your head there
is no such thing and now he's kind of
and he's cursed by the ghost of Sigmund
Freud and he comes to him in the middle
of the night and says you know you're
doing you're really hurting people by
your saying that there's no such thing
as neuroses so you're gonna start
feeling everything that all your people
are feeling and that you've been mocking
all this time and then he wakes up and
he start it starts to happen and it's a
very very funny description a very funny
story and it was ultimately blocked by
at the time by Davis Entertainment for
20th Century Fox and I worked with Fox
and Davis developing the script I did
drafts of different drafts of the script
they kept pre optioning it and
ultimately it just sort of did you sort
of never never went anywhere after that
so I got it back but I it's it's just a
great you know big broad character
comedy so I'm hoping one day it'll find
its place but that was the first the
first the first sale and very shortly
after that I had my second sale which
was just kind of amazing that it all
happened at once it was a an independent
film was a spec script that I wrote
called who's on first there's a
romantic comedy and it was ultimately
bought by an independent film company
and they made the film under the title
if you only knew and select between and
within like one year or six months or
something I was able to sell these two
scripts the film that was made it took a
little while to get may took a few years
over the course of a few years to get
made and released but but yeah that was
that was really kind of a fun beginning
and the whole point is when you sell
something is to be able to parlay that
into selling something else so I got a
lot of meetings at the time and and you
know I sort of got on the radar of
things and you try to work that you know
try to get other work from it and all of
that so it was it was good when you
talked about previously having these
scripts that you've written but they
they've sort of been there
v live life you know they're they what
are you doing to know if it's the right
time you said it's sort of whatever's
out in the ether are you looking through
the news everywhere it's it's it's more
general sense but I mean I think for
example this script Manhattan Transfer
which I ended up changing the title to
reverse psychology over time you know
there are different places now that that
will make maybe it's not a feature film
maybe it's you know a movie for crackle
or some you know some you know entered
Internet or streaming service that that
make that's starting to produce their
own comedies you know there's that whole
concept like what what else is out there
where you can now sell this kind of
material and you know just updated for
you know for where we are today there's
that I wrote a script a long time ago
called red hot mamas which was about
three women of a certain age single
women of a certain age who end up
winning a trip to a Caribbean island and
they take the trip together not
realizing that they're landing their
smack in the middle of college Spring
Break and it's the story about how these
these women in their late forties end up
end up being pursued by these these
college guys were twenty and you know
it's a little American Pie or whatever
but that that was it you know as a funny
script you know didn't sell back then
now there's this whole you know a big
proliferation of you know women's
comedies broad women's comedies from
bridesmaids to bad moms they're making
bad moms Christmas coming up this year
there's a movie that was at Sundance I
think called mom's lunch out or
something about moms great lunch or
something that got a lot of attention so
we're out again with red hot mamas we've
retitled it milfs and it's and and what
I did was I rewrote it a little bit ago
and I kind of cut the got the young guys
a bit and sort of amped up the women's
roles more so it's really really the
women's story the guys are there the
story is similar but I kind of I kind of
really focused on the women more and did
more work on them and and we're going
out with we're out with it again you
know trying to get interested in it
because because fun women's women's
comedies women empowerment comedies
women of a certain age you know you know
doing crazy things there's a market for
it now so there's that kind of thing so
that that was something that evolved
over over time you know bridesmaids was
just you know it could have been a
one-off and it turned out to be
something that really affected and
changed you know the film business in a
way the comedy business and certainly
Melissa McCarthy from that she kind of
she changed a bit of the face of comedy
what's with what studios are making you
know what comes to comedy you know so so
there's a new you know so there's that
you know there's that that would that
kind of thing that's out in the
zeitgeist so basically oh sometimes you
know if it's if it's based on a true
story
you know sometimes like III have the
rights to a book called rescuing Riley
which is about of a true story about a
man who rescues a dog from a canyon and
how he saves the dog's life and how the
dog kind of saves his life emotionally
as a result of it it's well it's a
wonderful book and we've been out with
they're trying to get it set up and and
all of that and then a dog's purpose was
coming out and I said to my agent you
know dogs purpose is is I read the book
it's a you know a great book I knew the
film would be good I had a feeling it
would do well get a lot of attention I
said everybody's gonna be looking for
their dog movie you know this might be a
good time to really put a push on
rescuing Riley so it's out there again
in a bigger way yeah that kind of thing
you know because it is a roller coaster
and you never know I mean some scripts
that I've written some screenplays
they're dated and you know that the
topic just doesn't work anymore and you
know
just put them aside what would you
consider as your biggest success thus
far and where were you and your life
when it occurred no it's interesting
story I may have to think about that
okay
my big success well you know I wrote
over the course of that six years I
wrote a total of 13 movies in a row for
the Hallmark Channel and what happened
there was I had written a spec
screenplay called the wish list that I
wrote as kind of big romantic comedy
star driven romantic comedy as a feature
and it didn't sell but was really funny
script was very high concept great
characters and just at that time this is
probably you know 2008 maybe 2009 it
went to the Hallmark Channel because
they were looking for romantic comedies
high-concept romantic comedies and they
were kind of this programming was
shifting a little bit and you know if I
could get him it as a TV movie I was
thrilled you know I just wanted the
movie to be say this movie have you seen
the movie made and they read it they
really liked it and it ended up being
being picked up by them I rewrote it for
them rewrote it to you know sort of make
it a little more Hallmark Channel
friendly and it was a hit it did really
well I was very proud of it they were
very happy with it and then I just got
hired to you know over the course of the
years to do to do some adaptations to
pitch original things I had three other
original screenplays that I wrote that
they ended up buying and I ended up that
I had there was there was spec scripts
that I ended up repurposing for them one
was a holiday film called hitched for
the holidays which was a really really
fun funny sort of comedy very romantic
comedy of errors set around the holidays
and that was that was on a bit in 2012 I
think so it was a really great I mean I
love doing the work for them and I'm
continuing to do other things for them
and and but this run of work was very I
was just you know it was really a really
really high point for me you know to be
able to work regularly you know I was
saying this business if you can work and
get paid fairly regularly you're doing
okay you know I mean they're gonna be
the people who you know make making the
millions of dollars all the time but
basically if you're working pretty
regularly
you know and getting things made you
doing well so I was really really proud
of that so to me that's probably the
make my major accomplishment being able
to to write so many films over the
course of a relatively short period of
time and I wrote a couple of stage plays
in between and I wrote a pilot as well
in between that period and I rewrote a
holiday movie four of what was ABC
Family Channel at the time during this
whole this whole period so you know just
being able to work regularly on a lot of
things and see things made to see as
many things made as I was as I was
fortunate enough to see during this
particular period was I think really my
favorite accomplishment and what I'm
maybe most proud of
so it's interesting because it sounds
like that was during the Great Recession
well it's very funny
it's it's low yes in fact you know what
this happened shortly aunts all start
happening after the writers strike was
over the writers strike was I think 2007
in the beginning of 2008 and they bought
that script either the end of 2008 or
beginning of 2009 at a time when you
know people were not working I was
working much less before the writers
strike and then after the writers strike
it was just accidental it was just fluky
but it is kind of ironic that you know
at a time where the studio's were
pulling back on everything and the
network's were pulling back and it took
a long time for writers to sort of get
back into a groove and all of that to
get back to a new normal
not that long after that you know my
career really sort of hit its stride so
it's kind of interesting it's
interesting you know we were just
speaking briefly off-camera about just
how someone can be let's say for lack of
a better word hot in one sort of genre
or style of film and then struggle to
find work because that's just not part
of movie culture yeah there's a shelf
life I think to to to not necessarily
one's ability but one's purview you know
in terms of what you write the John Rose
come and go you know you know certainly
if you write superhero movies these days
or you know grab things based on graphic
novels or things like that or if you
write horror or whatever it is there's
always a place for that but but because
of the way the
the films that are made at studios now
how different it is then it used to be
you know the course of time how much
everything has to be there much bigger
or very very star driven or comic book
driven or something it's it's a little
harder you know to kind of make your
mark in movies than it used to be and
people who were very successful selling
a lot of spec screenplays you know back
in the day and getting high concept
comedies made or whatever they have
great run you know but but they but a
lot of those people had to reinvent
themselves or just we're not able to
because of having to move into TV or
something like that which is great I
mean TVs you know people say TVs we're
all the great stuff that's being done
but you know you have to you always have
to reinvent yourself you can't rest on
your laurels no matter how successful
you are you know because things can
disappear very very quickly and it may
have nothing to do with you it's just
the you know kind of just the the
uncertainty of the business and the
changes in the business and the
financial changes that happen and all of
that so you have to kind of be very open
to to knowing first of all when you're
when you're doing something and you're
successful you have to really be
grateful and really remember that this
may disappear tomorrow so enjoy every
second because you know it's it doesn't
come around that often so that's the
number one thing but after that you have
to be really open to to what else is out
there and what else you can do
and that's important yeah you have to
have a little foresight with that which
we didn't always have to now things have
changed a bit for that how do you think
we can kind of get our finger on the
pulse of what could be I mean I I know
you know besides being see jobs yeah
yeah well it's funny because you know if
you come up with a night you know if
there's something out there in the
zeitgeist right now you know you could
say by the time you pitch it there 15 of
those movies in production or seven TVs
the pilots that have just been bought so
it's very hard to kind of you have to
kind of be a little ahead of the curve
but not so far ahead of the curve
that that people don't know what they're
talking about or it's too much of a jump
and not right in the middle of the curve
because everybody else is probably doing
it so it's hard I mean I think it's you
know a lot of it is just luck you know a
lot of it is just coming up with an idea
that just happens to hit and and it's
just right before there's something out
there in the world that that's that's
going to affect it you know so you you
want to kind of be
little ahead of the curve how you figure
out how to get ahead of the curve is
difficult you know sometimes you just
you just there's a trend that's starting
to happen or something you know about
and it doesn't have to be anything that
that's that's that esoteric it's just
like where is the world sort of moving
toward a little bit you know but then
you don't want to be too ahead of the
curve because because it seems too risky
or people don't really get it and then
if you if you've missed the curve
altogether which is very easy to do
because things happen so quickly then
you know sometimes you just you know you
just lose that but it's hard to predict
I mean I yeah they always say you should
just you should by and large write what
you feel you can write best what you're
most passionate about what means the
most to you and everything else sort of
will fall into place
you know you you you little find its
place you just have two other patients -
you know - after you write it -
sometimes it takes a longer time than
others for things to find the place or
if I think that curve to that curve to
come back again you know that world to
come back again that you know that's
right for your script the definition of
high-concept sometimes I struggle with
it myself and then I I hear it and I go
okay and I forget so generally it's
considered an idea that you can that
that's is very easily understandable and
if a sentence a couple of sentences you
know if you're pitching something pitch
a high pitch a high concept three
secretaries conspired to murder their
boss 9:00 to 5:00 you know an actor
dresses as a woman to get to get a job
on a soap opera because he can't get any
other work and learns to be learns to
appreciate women more as a result of it
Tutsi I mean that kind of thing you know
something that has a high now again
those movies are quite a little less a
little less popular now those high
concept comedies or those high concept
ideas but you still need a concept that
is strong and simple to to understand
and for people to get you know what
how will they market it you know what
will be on the poster what will be in
the trailer versus people to get it you
know and it doesn't have to be anything
that that while did that imaginative but
it says to be relatively simple to state
otherwise sometimes ideas get so
complicated that they get very
convoluted and that shows up in the in
the writing and sometimes the film
itself so it's about keeping it simple
but interesting and and and I don't know
if lack of a better word clever and
and unique so can someone sort of bounce
that idea off someone that like hey you
know this is sort of the logline for my
script or whatever and and if the person
just doesn't get it then they know I
need to refine it right right I mean I I
mean I definitely gone in to pitch ideas
you know this for a film or TV pilot or
something and you know I I think I get
it and I think it's a good idea and then
some of us and well I like the idea it's
a little complicated though because
because of a B and C and and not to me
it's like oh well I get it you know I
know I know what the idea I can totally
see how this idea can work but if I were
to write that I do myself and sometimes
I'll go back and try to outline it a
little bit just to see if to test it and
I'll realize yeah I just cut it it's a
little complicated it sounds
high-concept it sounds simple and fun
and you can see what the movie is you
know you can see the whole movies like I
like a carpet that rolls that in front
of you you can just see the whole thing
what it is but sometimes it's not you
know sometimes it is more complicated
than you think so there has to be kind
of a a you know sometimes people say god
I wish I thought of that idea you know
something is just this simple beautiful
in the simplicity you know and yet again
three secretaries conspired to murder
their boss you know a comedy I mean you
just something that's just simple and
people relate to and people get I mean
you know I've written a lot of high
concept comedies and it's just kind of a
hard to explain it's like one of those
things you know it when you hear it
right right but but like you know my
movie Manhattan Transfer you know I gave
you the log lines the high-concept radio
shrink text that's to take on the
neuroses of all of his callers on this
the most important week of his life yeah
you see what the movies about it's a
high concept but there are they're hard
to come by nowadays they they don't make
quite as many of those as films I don't
make quite as many of those high concept
movies often were comedies sometimes
they were you know diehard was high
concept you know what Lethal Weapon was
a high concept you know just just just
you know you could express the idea of
the movie in you know a sentence or two
and you totally got it you know that's
kind of what it is you may see more than
a television now you know I don't know
you know if I was if I anytime I would
I'm going to pitch something you know
I'm trying to go and you try to go in
and pitch something that's that's
relatively clean
and simple to understand in terms of
what the world is going to be what where
the entertainment value is going to come
from where the conflict can be in a lot
of it is just inherent in those couple
of sentences and and sometimes it makes
a good film or TV series sometimes it
doesn't you know it's not everything but
if you've got a good character attached
to it you know chances are you have a
good shot of at least having a good
piece of material from it so if it's too
wordy but it needs to be reduced yeah
and you know like anything that if you
when you start explaining anything to
somebody you know and wait and people
who are not sort of natural pictures of
stories or don't do it for a living or
whatever you know somebody's like
somebody will come to me and say I just
had the most amazing experience you've
got to write a movie about this and so
what is it and they'll say well okay I
was standing on a street corner and
before you know it they're talking for
20 minutes about this story you lost you
got lost that minute for and there's
there's no story to it or you think
there's something funny but it's just
too complicated what's the movie what's
the story you know why am I gonna laugh
what I do with that you know there's a
lot of that so yeah you have to keep it
you have to keep it simple you know and
unique let's talk about dialogue do you
tell the characters what to say or are
you almost hearing them tell you do you
it's a good question you know I think in
dialogue they kind of say that you can't
really teach somebody how to write
dialogue you can do somebody head--it
you can show somebody how to write more
tightly or more naturally but basically
dialogue is something that you know you
need to have a feel for you don't I mean
it's a heart it's not like teaching
structure or something like that
and I think I think it's a combination
of the two things you said I think your
characters speaking to you hopefully you
created a unique enough character or a
character with and with a strong enough
sense of who they are or what they're
you know how you would describe that
character and what their journey is
gonna be emotional journey is going to
be that the words kind of they kind of
they don't write themselves in it
necessarily but they but but it's it's
like the track that the train is running
on so so you know you you know what the
characters about you know where they're
gonna go you know what they're doing
right you know what they're doing wrong
and and what you want them to be and how
they talk needs to match that basis of
who they are you know if that's clear so
that so there's that you find that when
you start writing dialogues sometimes
the characters talk differently than you
then you expect that evolves you know in
that and that can be very interesting
and sometimes your character changes as
a result of your dialogue but by and
large you know that you know it's we're
using our voices we're using voices of
people we know we're using Cadence's
we're using regional you know words you
know it's it's a combination of a lot of
things but it does in a way it does
write itself you know you're the you're
the driver but you know it does kind of
roll out but again a dialogue you know
it's about how do you write natural
dialogue how do you how do you write the
way people really speak and it's cadence
and it's it's it's simplicity of words
it's it's you know expressing saying the
most amount the most amount of ideas and
the least amount of letters basically at
least amount of words and to keep it all
moving forward so it's it's hard I think
you kind of either write good dialogue
or you don't I think it's a tough one
well for your stage plays is rehearsal
really the only place that you can kind
of try out to see if that dialogue for
the character works the Bartles of
critical where right now where we're
reading through the play we're might
directors dividing the play into beads
and sections and and we're really
focusing on yeah after we've read
through it all together now we're
focusing on the individual words and to
see exactly what's working and you know
what what words really don't quite make
sense so what what I have in my mind
that the actresses aren't necessarily
feeling or getting or they don't quite
know how to say it or the director isn't
sure and that's an amazing process you
know it's like a fantastic process so
being able to hone the words it's kind
of rare you know do just just any a
table read of your script before
something is produced which doesn't
always happen is really really helpful
you have to hear other voices of the
ones in your head
you know you have to hear them say the
words so it sounds like four scripts
then you wouldn't always get a chance
you might just get notes back right you
get you get a lot of notes back but it's
but if you you know you know you unless
you on your own before you turn in a
script have you no gift gather some
actors and and you know try to try to
test it out you can do that but by and
large you write a script you turn it in
you get notes they'll and then then the
notes come with dialogue issues I don't
understand this line
this isn't funnier love that line this
works this doesn't you know could you
add a little bit put a little twist on
it that's duplicated you know that kind
of thing but which is very helpful and
it's all like I look at the scripts it's
just this big piece of clay that you
know you're constantly molding and
shaping and you know it's just sort of
moving with and trying to find the shape
to it and until you have your you know
the piece of pottery that you're trying
to make you know it's it's a lot a lot
of changes you know they always say they
say the writing is rewriting you know
and that's really you know and that's so
important you know I'm a big believer in
rewriting I'm fine about rewriting as
long as it makes sense and it's not just
to do it to because you do make things
better you know you can't get it on one
fell swoop at least I can you know you
you have to write and rewrite it and so
that really work on it and think about
it and get some distance from the
material to you know so that you can
sort of look at it with your own fresh
eyes and you have a much better sense of
what works and what doesn't work I find
some of the most interesting dialogue
just being in LA and hearing to people
for maybe like less than a minute right
you could take so much from that you
ever do that okay you could build a
whole hearing things writing things down
writing down expressions like oh my god
what a great expression what does that
mean I'm gonna take that you know or it
just the dynamic between people you know
kind of kinds of relationships who's
talking to who at the supermarket
listening to a couple arguing or or
being too nice to each other or whatever
it is you know it's it's fascinating I'm
always writing things down yeah so in
terms of being a writer and wanting to
add that dialogue how much are you
paying attention to seeing a couple in a
restaurant let's say and maybe little is
being said and you
how there's like some tension or sorry
well you know a lot is said with that
being said at all there's always that
you know and subtext is very important
in your writing so you're not just you
know you're not just you you know it's
not just the dialogue has like some
depth to it and and what your to exact
what they're saying is not necessarily
what they mean you know they're saying a
to really mean B because they're there
their intention to see you know there's
that so there are different layers to
the to the dialogue and sometimes
honestly you don't know know about that
until you write it and until you look
look back on it and say wow that was
kind of interesting or like that speech
didn't really go in the direction I
thought it would and yet it's kind of an
interesting twist you know but you just
try to make it real you try to make it
the way real people interact in real
situations if it's that kind of
certainly if it's that kind of moving so
you recommend that to other writers in
terms of getting enriching dialogue yes
pay attention pay attention the world
around you and you know I something I
watch I'll watch the movie or something
on TV or whatever and and I'll look at
like the the the the run of dialogue
would speak Manama phenomenal speech you
know and it by you know phenomenal piece
of dial you know I love done the
newsroom there in Sorkin show the HBO
show and and you know I would literally
just like just look at it just playback
over and over though certain sections of
that show and and the way that dialogue
was constructed and you know he's such a
genius in terms of constructing dialogue
and the word that he has is people use
but you can learn so much from that you
can be so inspired and and then put your
own voice into that kind of thing and
again a lot of a lot of writing dialogue
is cadence and and personality and and
things like that and trying to have
characters sound different you know so
that not every character sounds exactly
the same you know you give every
character their own voice which is
tricky it's hard to do but but that's
that's also really important and you
have to create that a little bit of you
have to create character you know
beneath you know character that's that's
kind of driving that dialogue for that
even if it's just the you know a
supporting character somebody we don't
see very much but yeah you kind of you
got to pay attention to what's around
you it's you know the best things are
out of reality also too what about
writing for a specific time period I
mean you would take let's say two men in
the 40s in a newsroom we're going to
speak it probably much more
eloquent fashion versus sort of the bro
culture of today which is or dude you
know yeah yeah it's very very different
very different it looked people in the
70s and 80s talk differently in the 90s
and the lows you know I mean it's it's
over the 40s 50s it's all very different
but the basic community of communicating
you know having clear interesting words
that lead you to a particular point
that's always what you know it is it's
how you get there it's been a little bit
different and writing anything I've
written that's had a interest like I
wrote a Christmas movie for Hallmark few
years ago and and there were flashbacks
to the 1920s and I had a write dialogue
that was seemed about right for the
1920s and it was just cadence you know
it was just being a little bit more
formal you know a little bit more on the
nose maybe with some of the things that
were said and it was fine you know and
it's just I think it worked you know I
mean it wasn't about using it using
going back and say now what word did
they use in the 1920s for you know
automobile you know was something I mean
it wasn't that it was just it was a
feeling it was a texture to the words so
that can be really fun you know because
we don't know exactly know how people
talked I mean yes we have movies from
back then and we can see but we're still
filtering those things through it
through a contemporary perspective so
it's not going to be quite like it was
back then and you want people to be able
to relate to it and understand it
is there a specific structure you use in
your screen flips yeah I mean they say
there's a you know I generally you know
defer to the classic storytelling
structure which is which is the three
act the three act structure the the the
different that likes of a series of
movements across across the whole script
I break it down into into three acts
four quarters twelve twelve sequences
yeah I mean III honestly anytime I try
to mix it up a little bit less but
there's not a big believer in drawing
inside the lines and then messing it up
you know but at least knowing that
you've got your framework the way the
way the way that that these story most
stories are told best and most
effectively and then you can kind of
mess it up and smudge it up and you know
kind of put your stamp on it you know
and all of that every I'm not such a big
believer that that what's supposed to
happen on page 60 happens exactly on
page 60 well if it's page 58 or 63 or if
it based upon the length you have script
42 as long as the movements or the
proportion of your story is right the
the the the movements you know kind of
our kind of the the kind of traditional
store in a traditional classic
storytelling traditional always sounds
like it's you know you're just in a box
that's that to me is important but but I
I'm a big believer in structure I
believe you get really found out that
but why your story isn't working when
you kind of when you kind of don't
follow some kind of structure you know
some kind of classic will be moving the
storytelling structure so going back to
when you were at the writers boot camp
how would you know a story was great but
it just needed to have more structure
and fused in it well sometimes I I
believe you can structure any story you
have to have enough of a story you have
to have enough of it of an enough of a
kind of about of a way to expand that
story into a full movie you know
sometimes you watch a movie you got
nothing happened in that movie or it was
what a bunch of nothing you know
whatever it was really because they may
not have been enough story sometimes my
very first screenplay I I had three
different ideas for scripts and I ended
up putting all three together and I
found my story individually each story
may not have been
somehow or other all three of those
ideas together just sort of work fit
like this puzzle and I was able to you
know to create this script so there's
that you know it's kind of is there's
that approach to it but it you know
basically you know a good story when you
hear or do you know the beginnings of a
good story a story that has potential or
an interesting character or a kind of a
lot of stories are just set up it's like
well ba bla bla bla bla bla bla well
that's great but like what happens then
because that's only taking me through
the first act and the second act is
always the most difficult act if you
don't know where you're going and most
anybody can write the first act of a
script but it's where it goes from there
that that's tricky so sometimes an idea
may be just all set up and there's not
much beyond that but if you take another
idea and pare it and another idea and
bring it in and kind of layer it then
you may have more of that story it's
about finding the story you can look
like I said you can structure anything
you can create a structure as long as
there's enough story and finding that
story you know which is the challenge
we've heard screenwriters use this
phrase cracking the story so what does
that mean exactly
but cracking the story is is it's kind
of to continue probably we're talking
just talking about it's you have a story
you have the beginnings of a story but
then you're beat you beat at the store
you create the whole story you roll out
the carpet basically the whole story so
you don't really crack the story and it
may be more of a TV term than a film
term I'm not sure but but you don't
crack the story until you are able to
you know sort of you can tell the story
from start to finish and any of the
holes in it are filled and I mean that's
my interpretation of it I mean you know
that you just you know or you know the
the concept of cracking something is
like oh that was what was missing we got
it now we crack the story and the rest
of it just falls into place but so
there's that but also I think the
concept of just being able to tell the
story from start to finish if I have to
look if I send in a pitch let's say I
write up a pitch to send into you know a
producer a network or something for for
a movie or a TV pilot or something
I don't just I may send a premise line
and see if just the general premise line
is of interest and they may say oh no
we're doing something like that oh
that's great give me more I will give
them the story from start to finish
doesn't have to be very long it could be
a page and a half that I'm
but at least I'm not just giving them
preamble I'm not just giving them the
first act of something I'm not just
giving them you know like a tease I'm
basically telling them where that
cracking that story for them I'm telling
them where that could move that story is
gonna go from start to finish
not necessarily in great detail
sometimes in more detail but it's really
about being able to show that this is an
entire story this is where this will
move and then we can fill it in and you
know and amplify it as we go along so
it's it's really being able to tell the
story from start to finish for me anyway
that's my interpretation of it so what
about those writers who say sometimes
they begin something without knowing the
ending yeah well I've done that oh you
have I've done that you know or the
ending has changed a lot you know with
again with April May and June with this
play I didn't know I didn't know what
they were gonna find I didn't know that
in the at the end of the first act that
we're gonna find the sisters were gonna
find something that just it became the
obvious it became the thing that was
driving me I didn't even realize it and
I didn't know what that thing was gonna
be until I thought about it
so yeah that was a case where I really
really didn't know I've definitely
written things where you know you'd if
you're writing a romantic comedy
generally the couple will get back
together in the end you know there's all
of that there's some you know kind of
some Givens but yeah sometimes you don't
know frankly I do think it's better
better to know or at least have some
idea it's like getting in your car and
saying well I know how to get halfway
there but like I don't really know where
I'm going after that you know it you're
gonna be stuck in the middle of nowhere
so it's not dissimilar with a with a
story I I prefer to know where I was
going and I think you know certainly you
know before you start writing and
sitting down and writing it you should
have a pretty good idea of where you're
going and if it does evolve or make
several changes along the way great you
know work with it see where it takes you
you know it the stories unfold on their
own sometimes they you know but I think
it's helpful to I'm like I said a big
believer in structure but I have and and
you know having the beats out before I
start writing something you know from
start to finish but we can be surprised
and I've definitely been times that I
have not known exactly where I was going
until I got there
you ever given up on a script because
you just lost interest here and there
you know I I generally don't start
writing something unless I have done
enough outlining and enough enough
exploration of the idea to know it's
worth going to script yeah particularly
I'm writing something on spec there are
definitely things I've written on spec
that I've stuck a few things I've
started and for some reason I've just
sort of abandoned because I I felt like
if I can go back and finish this some
time if I want to but it's not great
enough it's not gonna be unique enough
so it becomes a bit of an exercise but
by and large I've always tried not to
start writing something unless I was
unless I felt it was something I was
going to be able to finish or that it
was weren't really worth doing it's like
reading a book you know it's like I
tried if I'm reading a book if I'm if I
go to the trouble of starting to read it
I might as well finish it you know but
unless an idea is terrible you know we
don't always have great ideas sometimes
this is just not enough there but you
can I usually know that in the outline
stage to save me the you know the the
the hardship of writing the script and
the you know having it sort of like kill
it basically so what if you meet with a
writer that's you know new to the
industry or you know baby writer
whatever you want to call and they just
have a slew of unfinished scripts well
there's a reason you have a slew of
unfinished scripts you know you need
especially if we started enough writing
you need one or two good solid finished
scripts so when I hear somebody has a
slew of unfinished scripts it means that
they're really not picking and choosing
their stories well you know that they're
really not they're not passionate enough
about the story or they're cheating
themselves about about what the story is
about or they're trying to just you know
write a thriller because they think
that's gonna sell or something like that
yeah and and a lot of people start
writing without having the tools the
necessary tools you know everybody
thinks all I can write you know but they
don't really understand structure they
don't really understand and I'm not
saying you have to take a course in it
or whatever but you know you you you
have to you have done your homework you
know in one way or another and
understand how to tell a story
cinematically or for television and not
everybody has done that some people just
jump in and they're not really ready
can you take us through your outlining
process sure
generally what I'll do is I'll start
with the premise line I'll write out a
premise line sort of basically for me
like the foundation of the script a
couple of sentences take take you know
let's start to finish and then I'll
expand that into I know maybe two three
four pages there's sort of write it in
sections so I'll divide it in two into
three basically if it's a movie three
movie acts but you know a more in
quarters so it's like the equivalent of
a quarter quarter quarter quarter which
takes me through the four quarters or
the three acts of the of the movie so
it's I can keep it because one of the
things that happens when you start
writing it for me and you when I start
writing out and at writing outline in
you know the prose form is that you know
if you don't if you don't from me if I
don't kind of stop you know stop writing
at a certain point you know you end up
with let's say your outline is four-page
you're writing it just outlining at four
pages the first two pages may really
only be the first quarter of your script
because you know you you know you end up
writing so much and then then you have
to really then ultimately you end up
with kind of you know disproportionate
disproportionate acts so basically I'm
just trying to write it as tightly as I
can I'll write it long and then I'll
then I'll edit it but in the end I want
to end up with kind of four relatively
close descriptions of each quarter okay
so let's say that's that ends up being
three four pages whatever then if it's
on if it's an assignment then I'll then
I'll give it to the executive or
whatever I'll get notes on it rework it
and then if it's not for me I'll do the
same thing for myself and then what I do
is I divide the and this was a you know
really I have to credit writers boot
camp for this because they really this
was kind of the way they taught me how
to do it and how I always do it now and
I taught other people and I I think it's
pretty it's it's one of those things
that's just sort of like I don't think
it's uncommon way to do it but it kind
of boils it down to I think a really
effective way of doing it is that you
divide I divided up into twelve
sequences three sequences in the first
act six in the second act and three in
the third act of equal weight so
basically
you're writing 120 page script or you
know it's ten page as a sequence if
you're right if you're more like 100
page script it's eight or nine pages of
sequence and I feed out the list of
scenes so I'll take a right turn I
create a sequence sentence you know so
this is sequence 1 2 & 3 so added that
sequence sentence that I write right out
pulled from the outline the longer
outline I then write a list of the
scenes that will comprise that that that
that's sequence so I'll put like with
the scenes in a row and then I'll figure
out how many pages that scene will
approximately be so that I can add it up
add up each sequence and say at the end
those six scenes will equal eight and a
half pages or something and it's an
estimate it may sometimes I'm very off
but it's an estimate and this is just my
kind of organized way of doing it you
know and and how I don't get lost in the
process you know and I really kind of
stay on track this is just mine
everybody has their way of doing it and
so I do that so ultimately you end up
with basically 12 series of single
obscene lists so and which should eat
ultimately when you add it all up should
equal you know whatever your page desire
page count is 100 hundred and five pages
under 20 pages and estimate and then I
take that I put that on to my final
draft that lists on to my final draft
and I create a slug line over each one
you know interior living room night
exterior you know baseball field date
whatever and and so I have the line and
then I you know the what the what the
scene is about and then I have the slug
line so basically what I end up with is
a whole written script except for that
dialogue essentially and then you go in
and just you know you craft it and to me
it's just it's a very step-by-step
process so it's like an accordion you're
constantly expanding that accordion
until you have the whole script written
so that back that that works for me but
everybody does differently
what about writers who say they don't do
outlines if they can do it that's more
power to them you know I everybody you
know I look at like some of the Coen
Brothers movies you know some of the
great movies of our time right amazing
stories incredible character you know
incredibly creative
those movies are not all necessarily if
they outline how they outline but but
they don't feel as specifically
structured as most movies you see some
are some aren't I think they take you
know they just they're really brilliant
you know I think they're just able to
you know they're able to infuse their
stories in the in their own world in
their own structure you know for example
if you can do it it's great I I think I
do
I've just seen too many writers who get
lost in the process because they haven't
sort of laid it out enough ahead ahead
of time again it works for me I I and I
never look at it at any of this like oh
it's it's putting me in a box or I'm you
know using a formula it's not at all
it's just it's how I write and
especially when you're on a deadline and
you you know you have a limited amount
of time to write something it really
helps me you know you know move more
quickly and and having give me a system
of sort of checks and balances on my
material and and kind of force it and it
helps me not over write as well and
ultimately maybe spend not what lose too
much time on ston any material that I'm
not alternately going to put in the
script so what's your nemesis when
you're on a deadline you know changes
too many changes along the way you know
kind of any wholesale changes that that
may sort of crop up you know it's never
a problem you know kind of all it's just
shifting something rearranging something
changing dialogue you know threading
something in but sometimes there's that
wholesale change like the whole you
think something's working in that just
whole concept is just not it's just not
playing and you know it's not gonna you
know it's not going to it's not gonna in
the end you're gonna be found out and
it's not gonna work so it's like lifting
out a whole part and putting it aside
and reconfiguring any when you have to
do that in the middle it doesn't happen
often and again I think if you've got a
strong outline and and particularly if
it's if it's an assignment where you're
working with people and they're
approving an outline and they they're in
agreement with what you've written you
kind of trust stick to pretty much what
you know what you sold essentially but
yeah too many changes on it on it when
is a tight deadline can be really
difficult unexpected changes
can you tell us about an actual
assignment you've received and go
through the timeline and how you worked
your way through the deadline maybe you
came in over it maybe under it yeah well
you know it with assignments it's often
you know there's there's a particular
deadline or or or a goal you know that
you're trying to reach but then then the
goalposts keep changing just because
schedules change and and you know you
end up with more time sometimes and it
was a little less time you know I've
worked on films that that they were they
were they realize they needed to shoot a
little sooner than they thought so you
have to step it up but generally there's
enough time to to do your draft to do
several other drafts you can i-i've on a
lot of my TV movies I've worked
throughout you know throughout the
production even you know where where if
something has been a problem I've
changed something the director will call
and I'll change something or or alter
something or add a scene or that kind of
thing so sometimes it goes even you know
beyond the the just turning in the
script stage but you know generally the
way it goes is that you know you get the
outline approved you I I structure the
script I outline the script you know do
that step process that I do and then I
start writing and I do generally
schedule myself to you know take out
like a calendar and say you know okay
I've got six weeks to write this first
draft so I'm gonna but you know by this
week I want to get here I want to finish
it here I want to have two weeks to
rewrite that kind of thing and that
helps me
I just find writing anything down and
see anything visually really helps me
you know make it happen
and then I just try to just barrel
forward you know and and and and also if
I see honestly if I see a you know a
glitch or I see something that's not
working to make sure to check in with my
executive or my producer and say look
what do you think about this you know
I'm not I don't worry about like not
having the answer or something like that
I want to make sure that you know that
that were all in agreement on something
and I'm a big believer in collaboration
I like collaborating especially when
there are good ideas and you know and
and sometimes you just talk out a
problem and and just talking it out you
you can't it kind of opens up what the
problem is or the person you're talking
to has an idea well why don't you try
this that might work better and you know
and that's a big help and that can take
a little time you know that can take a
little time you have to
backtrack and then you know catch up
again but but by and large you know what
happens is where you where you end up
losing time is in the rewriting you know
we're not losing time as much as like
what the schedule can kind of kind of go
off kilter
you know because you may you may get
something in on time or even a little
bit earlier there are times I'll get
something in a little earlier than
expected
other times generally I think I hit the
deadline sometimes Oh maybe a little bit
late but but but then then it takes time
for everybody to read the script and and
for it to get input from maybe the
director if the director is on board and
then before you know it you're writing
another draft and another draft I mean
sometimes it could be several drafts
sometimes as many drafts it just depends
upon you know how many voices there are
and and and you know certain production
issues that they know are gonna happen
they they ready to shoot the script and
then their location scouting and they
realize they don't have a church but
they have a you know a bowling alley
whatever you know and so you have to
rearrange the scene for the location
that's available whether it can be an
issue sometimes you have to change there
lots of changes along the way one thing
is I'm gonna go into production that's
the you know that's the good news
that's the high-class problem because
you're making changes because the movies
actually being made but you know I I I
like to I like to work in waves you know
I like to work in movements you know
where where where I can I like what's
the word stages of closure so I like to
be able to finish a draft and then start
over and rewrite that draft and you know
so that it goes in more quicker stages
than one massively long stage you know
where you're just you know just
agonizing over something for months and
months and months I'd rather write it
faster hopefully it's good and then go
back and still clean sweep through it
and fix everything and just keep them
again and go back to the clay keep
molding the clay to me it's it's very
motivating to have new drafts all the
time you know and and to see to see that
you know you see everything sort of like
it's almost a graphic relief it sort of
comes out a little bit more at you and
you see what's happening but again
everybody's process is different you
know I over the course of time I become
very much not in agonizer right
an agonising writer I I I just you know
just pushed forward you know head down
push forward and and just really try to
try to do the best I can like everybody
does but you know I just worry less you
know I just try to do a great job
hopefully and and you know and just I
know I can fix things you know I always
feel like I have enough tools I've
written so many things that I do
understand how to how to fix things and
had to come up with ideas if somebody
doesn't like the product how I can fix
and how we can make it better
what why it work what was my intention
that kind of thing so so yeah do you get
nervous when there's nothing in the
works or is there a sense of freedom
because of the possibilities of what
could happen yeah yeah do you live off
that yeah if I thrive I mean I I
honestly because you know careers can be
such rollercoasters and you can go
through as a writer you can go through
many periods where you're really not
paid being you know really not working
for hire and you know hopefully you're
writing on your own and you're cranking
out material and you know you utilize in
the free time but because sometimes they
can be a lot of downtime it can be
nerve-racking
I like to I honestly the ideal thing is
to have enough work along the way the
way to keep to you to keep you
financially solvent but have a little
bit of downtime in between to work on
your own projects like you know if he
based upon what you'd like to do I mean
you know I like writing stage plays so I
like to have time here and there I I
recently I had shoulder surgery and I
was I was home it liked little I mostly
didn't leave the house for six weeks and
I but and I could I would I can only
write type with one hand but but I was
able to so use my other hand and I just
said you know what I've got I'm gonna
finish something at the end of the six
weeks I'm not tough being here I'm in
pain I'm gonna rights finish writing
something and I had started a new play
before I hadn't had the surgery and I
just literally just finished this new
play you know at the end of this period
and it was just so great and I'm very
happy with that particular play I'm
looking forward to continuing to work on
it but I didn't have an assignment at
that time so it did give me the freedom
to write that and during that period not
feeling all that great it was really
nice not to be not to have somebody
waiting for something for me because I
don't want to disappoint them or
something and because of the pain and
whatever so that was a good
period you know to not be you know to be
on assignment but by and large I like I
like it to be err on the side of Morris
on more work more paid work and more
assignment work than not it's very it's
very it's like charging your batteries
as charged you know I like the I like
just knowing this stuff out there that's
happening but I'm also pretty you know I
just I'm just always working on
something and writing something and no
we're trying to market old scripts or
work with my agent and get new meetings
and make things happen so I really
utilize the time to do that what's nice
about having a little free time is that
you can get back to your career and your
bigger picture of your career and not
you know because when you nose the
grindstone sometimes you forget well you
know but I don't have that script I was
trying to sell or I still do want to get
that assignment there I want to be on
that show there or whatever you know and
you just can't do it because you're so
focused on on your work you know and the
issue at hand so yeah it's nice to have
a combination of both but you're
probably better off having having the
work you know more work than not I think
well it goes back to what you said about
kind of like focusing too much on the
minutia okay so it sounds like it even
though you do like to be working and you
like to have stuff going it sounds like
yeah but that to have a little bit of a
breathing room you can kind of stand
back and see more yeah you can you can
you sometimes lose the big picture the
big picture you know when you when
you're you know when you're in the cave
and then when you get out of it then you
can look back and say okay I'm out now
I've got a little time where am i you
know let me let me read because you know
as a writer and it's similar for
directors and producers you know you you
you you have to be the master of your
own ship the you know the mr. Messer
your own destiny in terms of your career
you have to you have to keep it moving
forward if you want to keep working in
an agent is great but they can just do
so much you know in terms of it's really
up to us to to really stay on top of and
stay focused in terms of what our end
game is or what our goals are or you
know minded what are my goals my goals
are to you know keep writing movies that
get made and you know
you know right things that are
meaningful to me and that I hope people
will enjoy and and and all of that to
you know tell my stories and that kind
of thing but you know that doesn't just
happen you know and sometimes you have
to really keep your eye on the ball in
terms of because time goes very very
fast you know and and if it's not you
it'll be somebody else and you know we
had a finite amount of time on this
planet
absolutely and going back to when you
left one career and you don't have to
give to me he tells about it but were
you able to step back from a lot of
minutiae at that point because you
probably had more free time and it was
really it was a really weird time
because I was so used to getting a
steady paycheck you know and I had
fortunately I had you know especially
enough money to take to have the you
know time to go through this process and
until I got work again but that was a
big thing for me to kind of just be okay
about getting sporadic paychecks you
know and not knowing when the next
paycheck was gonna be then knowing this
is just a safety net basically and I had
and that was that part was difficult but
at that part but when I left that job
and started becoming a screenwriter TV
writer at that point it was all it was
all focus all the time for me I mean it
was just like I just dove into the deep
end and you know and there was so much
to do and so much to write and you know
you had a like he was like starting it
was starting a whole new career it was
just a lot to learn you know and a lot
and I'd be out there a lot and and you
know really just keep my eye on the ball
so it was an exciting time but you know
definitely challenging but but yeah it
was it was not a lot of not a lot of
down time and oh and also back then I
would feel very guilty about having
downtime I would just feel like I
shouldn't be going to the movies I
should be working on my new spec script
or something and then that was hard I
mean it took a long time for me to not
feel guilty about not working but that
eventually happened when I got enough
work and like okay I don't want to be
working you know at that moment you know
so that was that was okay but you go
through phases every career has has its
phases you know and we grow as people
and you know and as we experience more
you know and as you become more
confident or more just more
self-possessed or more you know just
lets beholden to the forces out there
you know well I think too it probably
did it take training for you to get out
of that nine-to-five or whatever it was
nine to seven minds well it can't you
know it kept me pretty structured you
know I mean it like I was so used to
that that kind of that I that kind of
nine to five or nine that job was like
nine to nine but I would you know I was
you know used to getting up early used
to you know just getting my work done
used to having a goal for everyday and
all that so that translated really well
when I was working on my own because
otherwise it might have been like oh my
god how am I gonna organize this what am
I gonna do you know that part wasn't it
wasn't an issue it was just like will I
get a job will I be then will I be
successful you know will I be able to
you know really make it go with this we
talked about where your characters come
from and what's your process for
developing okay well you know they say
that you want to put a character when
you move it you know for the beginning
of a movie or something you want to put
your character where they would least
like to be you know it's at a moment of
crossroads where their life is gonna
change and you're gonna take that
journey with them and you have to you
put them out of their there you get them
out of their comfort zone basically and
the reason they're there in a comfort
zone is because they're kind of doing
something wrong their personality
there's a there's something in that
personality that's that's you know
writers bootcamp calls it a misbehavior
it's a great word it's a adjectives to
describe what they're doing wrong how
they're negatively affecting other
people but we still care about them
anyway and it shows how they can change
so you find somebody you create a
character who is doing something wrong
or ineffectively and somebody's gonna
have to come into their life
who's gonna kind of turn them around and
compliment them and get the best out of
that personality and then have them make
that personality work for them so you're
just try to find a character and a
crossroads who's gonna do something and
interesting especially you're writing
things that are not plot driven
necessarily like you know the Bourne
Identity or something you know you're
writing you're writing a character if
you've run character driven things
whether it's a comedy or drama or you
know whatever but but there's you know
it's it's it's driven by character which
always make for the best stories and and
so then you figure out who needs to come
into that character's life to help help
them on this journey help them
accomplish this mission you know movies
are basically about a relationship about
two people on a chore
you know with with effort with people
around them and supporting characters
and an opponent and all that but it's
basically I boil it down to the main
character and who comes into their life
to go on that journey with them and what
is that relationship like so in creating
the main character you know whether it's
a man or a woman you know they always
say that that we we are our main
characters whoever we're writing we
could be writing a serial killer but you
know they're they are us you know that
we weren't fusing them with with our
point of view not our value is not our
history but but our what maybe what our
point of view is or how we see what
their point of view should be that makes
sense so part of it is knowing what the
journey take setting the character
creating an interesting character in an
interesting environment but knowing that
they need to be on a journey to solve
the issue of their life and the movie
and I start I start there is it
different for stage plays verses eyes a
little bit different you know it's um it
can be very similar but still even a
stage play you know you you you you want
to want that stage playtest to begin at
a moment of a very important moment for
that character's life the moment that
changes it all or you know that the time
that's gonna shift them as people and
and and their lives you know so they
walk over they they they emerge from
that that story you know kind of a
different person you know April May and
June is these three sisters come
together and they're all pretty much set
in their ways and they're okay the way
they are but by the end of this
afternoon they really have a better
understanding of who they are why
they've done done what they've done in
their lives and why they've reacted to
both of their dead parents slave parents
in such different ways and it's all
because of this kind of like combustion
that happens during with three people
these three women over the course of a
couple of hours in the afternoon so you
want them to come through the come
through their journey you know as a
changed person in some way some
characters don't need changing so that
may not be as an interesting a character
but we all need to do something better
we all need to do something more
effectively even it's if it's to learn
how to have a relationship with somebody
what's a romantic comedy except to you
know basically unexpected or mismatched
people who
sparks fly and then they realize that
they can make each other they can
complement each other make each other
better people and and be with somebody
that they never expected until maybe
they can't and then of course at the end
they do you know but it's finding people
at an interesting point in their life
you know who have something to learn so
let's take a writer that's maybe has to
dull or flat of a character versus one
that's it's too much stuff they're
putting too much right how do you know
well you know it you know you want to
keep your character on a track you know
and and you you want to have that having
a goal in mind you know whether the goal
is to have that romantic relationship to
rob that bank to to you know to come to
terms with their addiction you know
whatever it is you you you want them to
have an end goal and and keep them on a
track and as soon as you start getting
away from all of that sort of like the
the kind of interesting human moments
that may happen along the way of a
journey then you then you realize you're
kind of diffusing your story and you
know that we're losing the focus of the
character so I think usually pretty
enough pretty much know when you're when
you're going off the track when your
character is just not acting the way
they you'd like them to well I know
you've seen so many films and oh you're
also a film reviewer can you talk about
some of your favorite films where that
character starts out in a very
uncomfortable place yeah yeah well you
know comedies are always great you know
one of my favorite one of my favorite
movies favorite movie companies is
sixteen Candles the John Hughes movie
with Molly Ringwald and you know it the
great thing about that movie it's just
you know it's such a it's relatable you
got the you know the annoying
grandparents you got the clueless
parents you got the the annoying sister
you got all the dweeby kids in school
it's like everybody can execute can
relate to all of that and you know
Samantha Molly Ringwald's character
she's just you know she's in the worst
moment of her life you know she's w Burt
knows it's her birthday she's 16
everybody forgets the dorky guy likes
her the hot guy doesn't pay attention to
her you know it's just this little
microcosm and she's like so
uncomfortable and so self-conscious and
by the end of that she just gets a
little bit of confidence you know and
like the cute guy likes her and that's I
love that movie you know it's not it's
just funny but it's so sweet and so
smart
yeah that's one of my favorite
I mean and even Tutsi you know is you
know he's he's such a self possessed guy
but he's in such a bad place because he
has no money and he can't get a job and
he doesn't want to play a tomato the way
they want him to on commercials and all
of that and he just he just really goes
to the wall to try to do something to be
successful and it completely up ends his
life you know so he's definitely he's
out of his comfort zone but he makes the
best of it the move that movie is all
about being out of your comfort zone but
yet making it work for you which I like
but you know on a dramatic front you
know when you deal with with thrillers
or something you know those characters
have put in you know you know how it
silence of the lambs you know a great
film great book you know she's somebody
who's thrust and she's somebody who's
almost not ready to be thrust into this
horrifying world she is and and she's
she's got like such a a she's got
somebody in you know an Anthony Hopkins
character that you know who's such a
tests her so much and you know it was so
smart you know it's such a spider and
the fly kind of thing and she's so out
of her league that you know that that's
an interesting character who we begin
with in a very uncomfortable place who
is made even more uncomfortable if you
uses that discomfort uses that her past
you know the difficulty of her past to
really emerge through and really succeed
that's kind of fascinating how important
is it for you to have a strong personal
connection to the material that you're
writing oh I think it's really important
you know I think it's it's so important
you know if you're writing something for
you like a play and stage play or
something that's personal
obviously absolutely but even on
something that's not particularly about
you or something of your life and your
concern you have to find your way into
it and you have to find your way how do
you connect to it you are writing what
makes you the the the unique writer of
any any story or any script is your
perspective and what you bring to it if
if you and I were to write the same
script we bring bring we might get to
the same end goal and the story might
not be the similar but the how we get
there would be very different because
we'd be bringing our own experiences to
it and our own views of things and and
other people's views of things that
we've seen you know so yeah I think that
being able to connect to find stories
that should connect with our fine
create connections that you relate to
because it becomes very honest that way
and so that so whether it's comedy or
drama honesty and real experiences and
we'd like we talked about earlier the
things that you overhear people saying
in the supermarket that you can use
because that moved you or made you laugh
and you use that that's your you know
those connections are really really
critical I think to making to make for
good writing and good stories you know
it's you don't have to but I definitely
think it's a big help
why did you begin writing ah that's a
good question um you know I think I
started writing like when I started
writing you know my very first writing
that I did was I wrote movie reviews for
the high school newspaper and I think
part of it was there was a certain
escape factor to it back then I mean
certainly movies were a bit of an escape
and writing about them was like I just I
had a lot of thoughts about them you
know I loved movies and I read a lot of
film criticism as a kid and and it was
really you know a big part of my world
and and it meant a lot to me I was like
well I want to do that I can write that
and I've read so much I've seen so many
movies I can take it it's fun let me
take a crack at and it was fun and I and
I'd like being able to share opinions
and get conversations going about things
and hear people had different opinions
than mine and and all of that and it was
just nice again I just love craft
writing the words and crafting you know
crafting the words and it just sort of
evolved you know and I've always loved
movies and theater and and and
television and and stories and books and
telling stories and reading stories and
all of that so at a certain point you
know if you want to be part of that you
either are on one side of it or another
so I started off as a publicist
promoting other people's movies and
being able to talk about other people's
movies writing and selling other
people's movies but then at a certain
point I realized I wanted to start
telling those stories I wanted to be the
one to create those movies in those
stories that's sort of sort of starts
speaking to me much more than being on
the other side of the table as I call it
so yeah it just sort of evolved you know
and and and and also it's it ultimately
is something that I think I have you
know more of a talent at than other
things so you know you go where you you
have the most talent most ability
remember the defining moment when you
said I think I want to move on from the
publicist you
yes exactly I was there I could like it
was yesterday
my boss was leaving to go on a trip for
three weeks and she said to me you know
they want you to sign a contract here
and because I was a place where I think
they were gonna promote me to it like
give me a little bit of a promotion or
whatever some title promotion and and
give me some new duties or something and
she said so they want you to sign a
contract as well how long is the
contract Portia's well it's a six-year
contract it's two years two years in two
years and I and and she says so while
I'm away read it take a look at it and
then sign it in and when I come back
I'll sign it and you know we'll move
forward and when she was gone I was like
I can't sign that contract and I just
realized that it want to be there I just
I I just I it just wasn't right for me
you know it was a time jacket job at the
time and you know it was you know I was
like very political and and all of that
and not that you know screenwriting
doesn't have its own politics and all of
that but I don't know it just I just
felt it was something I just wasn't
accomplishing what I really wanted felt
I wanted to it at a really young age I
just still wasn't like I just felt like
it wasn't this wasn't where I needed to
be you know even though I was doing well
with it it wasn't where he needed to be
and my father was visiting me around
that time my father passed away last
year but he he was a very bottom line
kind of money-oriented kind of guy very
meeting potatoes and not a showbiz guy
at all and but I was supported what I
did but just you didn't have a great
sense of it and he said to me I said you
know dad they want me to sign a contract
honey I should do he goes well do you
want to stay there and I said I don't
and then he said well then you should
leave I said well I can't leave this job
this is a job that people aspire to you
know I like what what if you know is
well what do you want to do I said I
want to actually want to write I want to
write you know movies in television
because then that's what you should do
I said well you know but what if it
doesn't work out he says listen you
don't want to be my age and look back
and say I should have done it and then
it's too late
he says if that's what you have to do
you have to do it and I was like shocked
that he said that and not that I was
listening to him necessarily but it was
like it was coming from an interesting
place and I just thought about and I
said he's right I'm just gonna I'm not
gonna sign that contract and my boss
came back and she said so did you sign
the contract and I said no
she said oh so you just didn't get to it
yet I said no I'm not signing that
contract and she said you're not signing
the contract and I said no I said I'm
leaving I'm gonna write for television
and I did and then I called my father
and I said dad I quit my job and he said
you did what
how could you quit a job like that who
quits a job like that and you know for
years after that you know he would say
to me you know if you stayed there you
probably would've been president of that
place but I was just so glad to be gone
and it was a you know good experience
for certain things certainly helped me
in many many ways as a writer and as a
marketer of my material but it was that
was the time I knew I had it had to move
on and never looked at I never looked
back so when you got your things
together in a box or whatever and left
with did you feel a weight had been I
felt so great you know when I was when I
was saying goodbye to people is really
fine I don't mean to be arrogant too bad
or anything because it was just it was
not it was a difficult time you know you
know work wise and personally at that
time and I just I kind of need it to go
and I remember one was one of when
somebody I work with his seed said to me
you know what you're doing is is so
brave to leave and I said no wouldn't it
it would be more courageous to stay you
know meaning that like it was tougher to
stay than to go in a certain respect but
yet I knew I was dying I I didn't
realize what a you know what a deep pool
I would I would be I was diving into you
know becoming a writer I just it like
again like I said I just was soft a
mystic about it I just felt I wasn't
quite aware of the difficulties of it
you know and so to me it was just like
the the thing to do staying there would
it would have been more more difficult
but no I was I was happy to go by the
time I was I was done that's ready do
you think a lot of people do that in
Hollywood they stay in certain things
would be everybody in life because they
often stays and things that they're just
not happy with because sometimes they
don't know where to go you know I was
very very fortunate you know I I've
always had I kind of known what I wanted
to do I've had things that I'm
passionate about you know my work is my
is my enjoyment you know so I feel very
very fortunate with that but a lot of
people aren't happy in a job but they
don't really know what else they want to
do and I and I would never recommend
anybody just not be happy in something
in just up and leave without knowing
where they're going because it could
take a very long time to get another job
and you're always more
while you're employed you know whatever
you're doing so yeah but I think they're
definitely people who are you know
living those you know just desperate in
those desperate situations but you know
I encourage people you know who really
aren't happy and what they do to find
your passion and to figure out a way to
make it a career if you can not
everything can be you know not
everything is that monetizable or that
you know realistic but you know work is
a big part of our lives and it really
helps if you if you can enjoy it